as we've been doing those look backs at
the previous year in decades I suddenly
had this brilliant idea why not go a bit
back and feature fights from the 2000s
when you think about it the 2000s is
probably the era when a lot of us grew
up on anime behold the era of the big
three but trust me those popular shows
that set the landscape of this decade
wouldn't be all that you'll see in fact
I had some surprises in store for you
and while I doubt it knowing you guys
you might even be able to find a show
here with a fight that you overlooked by
accident well what are we waiting for
let's get the ball rolling and start
taking our furthest trip down memory
lane to date
[Music]
true to its artsy and unique form
samurai Champloo brings us the first
among the top fights of the 2000s here
Mugen and Jin battle courier the so
called hand of God this fight shows much
of samurai champloo appeal the artistic
shots are there and the simple fluid
sequencing of attacks is there too I
really like how non Mugen sword fights
in samurai champloo pretty much go
against the typical shown end style of
deadlocks and clashes of power instead
the fights are fast fluid and place
emphasis on dodging and moving according
to pre-planned moves Korea is just the
perfect type of opponent to set the two
main characters on and to establish the
overall power level in the series the
two of them got their asses handed to
them by the sheer genius and style of
their opponent
[Music]
mm is the era of the shounen jump big 3
and the first one to enter the list is
bleach with its ichigo vs. Grimmjow
fight
grimmjow is one of ichigo's most
memorable rivals and it's not a surprise
that their final fight delivered in all
regards personally I don't consider this
the best fight in terms of character
building or clash of ideals this fight
however is king when it comes to good
old slugfest as ichigo and Grimmjow went
at it war with unrestrained power just
as the 6th Espada wanted grimmjow may
not be ichigo's perfect foil but he sure
knows how to make an impact and despite
not having as much internal stakes of
some of the previous issue go fights
Grimmjow versus ichigo's final fight
remains one of the most memorable and
visually imprinting clashes in Bleach
feeling massively overwhelmed it should
go bet on all he had up to this point
his roar will and resolve with Orihime
faith to stake
Ichigo got that last push he needed and
ended up finishing Grimmjow with a slash
that also doubled as one of the best
fight screenshots in the ugh
[Music]
[Music]
now here's a show that's rather niche
compared to what we've taken a look at
so far 2007 s Morabito does start off
with a bank with a great fight coming in
as early as the third episode
visage shows off how much of a badass
female lead she is by taking on several
hunters at once the numbers disadvantage
doesn't seem to faze the seasoned
warrior one bit as she comes out right
on top although I've got to say is that
even really that surprising looking at
the clip you wouldn't expect Morabito to
be a 2007 show given how great the
fighting looked fight choreography and
the animation are all ahead of their
time in this series if you think that
the fight looks great then you might
want to watch the rest of the series
with its themes an intriguing story
marito is a gem that deserves more
appreciation
Tunde Goran and their battle against the
anti spirals is by far the show's
pinnacle as far as big fights go it has
all the trigger signatures over-the-top
action crazy twists and sacrifices and
the spine-tingling finish sequence
fueled by fiery voice acting and sarai
road days blasting in the background
thinking about it now just gives me
goosebumps and I'm sure the same goes
for some of you as well it's hard not to
like this fight because it's probably
pig TT GL and everything you love about
the show is condensed in this one
decisive fight with team guy Guren
carrying the hope of humanity on their
back the final battle of TT GL truly is
a landmark moment in the late 2000s it
capped off the show that put trigger on
the map and the studio hasn't looked
back ever since
[Music]
for the very few of you who didn't know
hunter hunter had an anime way back and
it's from there where we will be taking
a look at the next fight on the list
guru pika versus over again the brute of
the phantom troupe the unstoppable
Avakian takes on Korra pika in this
fight that showcases why fights in
Hunter hunter are so fun and
unpredictable I don't blame fans for
taking him for granted because he was
defeated so early but when he look at
the guy in a vacuum
he's just overwhelming that in turn
makes him the perfect opponent to put
over and build hype for Korra pikas
abilities as the giant brute of a man
gets absolutely destroyed by korra pika
through clever manipulations and
unpredictability ku refika was able to
snowball his advantage in the fight and
easily win even healing through Vogons
attack to his credit over gain was never
the dumb muscle to his boisterous
behavior and loud mouth make him seem to
be but he does find himself outmatched
here the icing on the cake is the reveal
of how korra pikas abilities counter his
enhancer ability the battles being
decided and even over again himself
knows it
[Music]
a fifth-place fight is a real
slobberknocker featuring Nakamura taking
on hawk Brian Hawk and taka Maura are
basically foils for each other
loud boisterous and perverted the Tewa
cut from the same cloth riding on a
winning streak and being carried by an
all-time high
Hawk confidently begins combat against
the Japanese opponent trading impactful
punches and swinging the momentum back
and forth it was really a war inside the
squared circle at the fights darkest
moment it's dark amorous unstoppable
rage that allows him to finally turn the
tides the intensity has been turned up
to such an extent that it allows him to
finally settle the score and put an end
to the undefeated streak of Brian Hawk
the over-the-top fight is part of what
makes it both such a classic where else
do you see non main characters being
featured in such epic showdowns the
fight makes taka Mora looks so badass
and needless to say he beat Hawk into
retirement
literally Nakamura won't be in another
fight as awesome as this one
[Music]
I'd be hard-pressed to write something
about the 2000s without at least
mentioning Cowboy Bebop one of the
landmark shows of that decade now for
this entry however we go past beyond the
much-loved series and take a look at a
fight from the movie the battle between
spike and Vincent really who doesn't
have a good ol fist fight to end an
amazing anime movie the two fighters
after numerous confrontations find
themselves in for one decisive faceoff
and they simply put out one of the best
unarmed combat sequences in anime the
actions fast and furious and their fight
spills all over the place after numerous
setbacks spike finally gets the upper
hand in what's been a touch-and-go
battle as an aside I also like how the
whole fight simply demonstrates spikes
endurance concurrently with his
vulnerabilities despite being the ACE
bounty hunter spike seems to be fighting
an uphill underdog battle here but you
just don't notice that at first because
of the cool sequences hand-to-hand
combat at its finest
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in contrast to the Clash of the Titans
we have an underdog fight for our third
place entry all you need to take a look
at is the build-up and the roles of the
two characters and it's not hard to
predict the winner of Gaara versus Rock
Lee on one hand you've got the arc
villain who's heavily featured
everywhere facing him is the resident
comedic side character who despite
kickin Sasuke's ass certainly stands no
chance I mean let's be realistic about
it however if you look at the fight
alone you don't get that impression from
the beginning of the fight
Rock Lee took on Gaara with all he had
and was seemingly on the verge of
victory in numerous instances if he
wasn't facing a main character for the
earth that kind of effort from Rock Lee
would have certainly knocked any
opponent senseless seemingly having an
answer for everything Gaara through it
here Lee looked at the top of his game
before finally taking the obligatory
loss there was no way that Rock Lee was
gonna win this but boy did he go out
like a true champion
[Music]
over the years a one-piece has given us
a lot of cool and emotional fights as
one of the biggest shown in series out
there it's bound to have several fights
that are contenders to make it on this
list now why did I choose Luffy's fight
versus Lucci specifically in addition to
the emotional context and the weight of
the fight I'd say that the battle
against Lucci is one of Luffy's fights
that is all about his raw power for a
lot of fights Luffy receives help in
true Shonen fashion whether it be
surviving crocodiles initial assaults
through luck or law helping out against
doflamingo and others however this
battle against Lucchese a good old
physical brother barring some
motivations from us op basically is a
battle that luffy won through effort not
a lot of plot-related device is going on
around to help Luffy secure the win and
were treated to a nice little slugfest
that features the two combatants
answering each other with blazingly hard
punches and physical feats
[Music]
[Music]
I've talked about this fight from sort
of the stranger before in fact they
talked another list that you might want
to check out too but I guess that's just
a testament as to how awesome this
climactic battle is throughout the movie
we've been treated to scenes of New
Orleans feats and the height for the
climactic battles over the roof all this
time we were made to wonder what Nanashi
could possibly do to defeat his opponent
who's been shown to have the strength of
an entire army and trust me that's no
exaggeration the fighter the altar is
probably one of the best pieces of anime
cinematography not just in the decade
but in anime history as a whole think
about that the intensity of the flights
been amped up and that's all thanks to
the animation the acting and the
soundtrack backing up the classic bout
if you have to pick an anime fight to
represent peak anime battles in the
2000s this one has got to be one of the
strongest candidate
as we conclude the list I got sucked
into a wave of nostalgia myself a more
overt 2010's guy if we're talking about
anime decades but the 2000s had a lot of
great highlights didn't if I do say so
myself from intense sword fights to
blitzing Lee fast fistfights and
emotional clashes this decade did have
it all perhaps you might have some other
fights that you can recommend from this
decade I and the rest of the community
would definitely love to hear from you
so what are you waiting for
surai discussion on the comments section
and we'll get to you in no time
so that's it for now see you next time
on Billy tube
[Music]